bonjour en merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors concrètement
pour comprendre la situation comment ça
se passe sur place pour les habitants de
cuba
oui alors vous avez une réforme qui a
été mis en place depuis le début de
l'année qui était la réunification de
deux monnaies qui existe est
initialement une monnaie qui était plus
tourné pour le marché vaut pour les
touristes et notre man et locales sur
lequel se faisait les échanges l'autre
monnaie qui étaient tournés vers les
touristes l'objectif était clair c'est
d'obtenir des devises étrangères après
cette réunification des deux monnaies
vous avez une inflexion est presque
structurel qui s'est fait parce que vous
aviez là la monnaie des changes des
cubains qui a été surévaluée et donc ils
nécessitaient effectivement des mesures
économiques et notamment de serment
marcher la planche à billets pour quel
pays pour que les cubains puissent
suivre ses pertes à son agression il ya
la pression très importante
cette inflation très importante elle est
notamment dû au fait vous avez un marché
noir extrêmement important qui est
beaucoup mieux fournis que le marché
traditionnel et qui fait que
naturellement les cubains se tourner
vers ce marché pour obtenir les produits
dont ils ne disposent pas sur le marché
traditionnel donc une prédation du
dollar sur ce marché noir est ce que le
problème qu'il ya actuellement à cuba
mais qu'effectivement pour tout ce qui
va être les produits de première
nécessité et enfin tous les produits
enfin vous avez un minimum syndical on
va dire comme ça qui est garantie par
l'état cubain mais pour fournir à leur
est pour fournir un peu plus ça va être
très compliqué pour les cubains du fait
notamment et bien de quoi des sanctions
économiques de l'embargo qui n'ont pas
accès en fait à ces produits là ils sont
obligés d'aller au marché noir de plus
eu avec justement cette réunification
des deux monnaies et le fait qu
auparavant c'était déjà le cas mais
c'est le cas depuis longtemps avec cette
prédation du dollar vous avez une
ambition spéculative qui est absolument
acquérir des dollars ou avant c'était la
devise est la devise qui était destiné
autorise au pouvoir voilà écoulées sur
le marché noir vous faire vous perdrez
spéculatifs tout simplement et c'est
tout le problème de 2,2 cette prédation
du dollar et de les monnaies étrangères
vous avez sur le territoire et qui
quelque chose d'assez similaire de ce
que pouvait vous trouvez au venezuela
par exemple alors les autorités veulent
miser notamment sur le tourisme un
secteur qui a bien sûr été fragilisée
par la crise sanitaire avec l'ouverture
des conditions visite des voyageurs avec
un assouplissement début du mois de
novembre est ce qu'on peut avoir de
l'espoir
oui oui c'est que la mesure principale
d'aider cuba récemment qui explique en
partie la place ont été cette
réunification des deux modèles qui on va
dire désolé manière assez logique
puisque vous aviez dû certes manière une
incubation de vitesse à cuba qui étaient
tournées à l'extérieur pour obtenir des
monnaies étrangères c'est ce qu'a besoin
cuba ils ne produisent avant chose dont
vous avez besoin de d'avoir des monnaies
étrangères à partir de cette monnaie à
partir de ce marché et le marché
intérieur qui se faisait à partir d'une
monnaie c'était ma logique puisque avec
les ambitions spéculatifs naturellement
de beaucoup ce que vous essayez de faire
c'est d'obtenir la monnaie la monnaie
qui était par les touristes les
touristes payer exclusivement sur cette
fois les avoir dans certains secteurs
alors qu'il aurait des permis payer
autrement il paye actuellement ça ou
alors payer directement au dollar et
donc du coup l'objectif était de été
spéculé donc c'est assez logique d'être
allé sur cette mesure après
effectivement il ya un autre problème
qui est plus structurel qui
effectivement la question des pénuries
qui sont assez assez récurrente donc
c'est la plus grave crise que nous avons
notamment par le fait que marché noir
est extrêmement important depuis la
période spéciale des années 90 c'est
très compliqué pour le tuba on n'est pas
au niveau de la période spéciale pour le
rappeler la plus grave crise depuis la
période spéciale est donc effectivement
bas le tout l'enjeu actuellement c'est
de réussir à ouvrir des marchés qui leur
permettent d'obtenir des devises
étrangères en fait d'apporter pour
pouvoir limiter cette pénurie d'obtenir
des dollars ou d'autres monnaies qui lui
permettent qui leur permettent de
commercer et de pouvoir et pour l'état
d' importer les produits dont ont besoin
les cubains et pour derrière amenuisé la
la prédation de ce marché noir brillant
activement ce sera plutôt positif le
fait qu'il ya un retour du tourisme donc
c'est effectivement l'un des secteurs
voire le secteur c'est difficile à
évaluer mais qui permet le plus de
ramener des des monnaies étrangères elle
a d'autres arrières par exemple vous
avez aussi la question des relations
diplomatiques avec les médecins qui sont
exportés aussi les expatriés qui
envoient de l'argent ou sur ces gens aux
anges la grosse importance qui a rappelé
que par exemple vous à dire le brésil
avec cuba avait d'excellentes relations
et où les relations se sont noircis du
fait de l'arrivée de paul sonara donc
par exemple les le les enjeux électoraux
qui a dans d'autres pays risquent
d'impacter cubain très certainement est
effectivement pour le moment c'est là
c'est la mesure de la de première
nécessité vous pouvez prendre le cube a
pour part avoir quelque chose
d'illogique à cuba à deux vitesses quoi
lorsque très clairement les cubains ne
fonctionne pas à deux vitesses il
s'échange les alimente un marché noir
très naturellement il est vrai voilà
et donc effectivement l'arrivée 2 enfin
la réouverture pour les touristes
risquent de faire du bien du du bien à
cuba après de manière générale le vous
avez tout de même une crise qui est
assez importante le marché noir qui
comme vous l'avez dit extrêmement
important en parle de 6900 % d'inflation
du marché nord qui continue sa prédation
sur le marché traditionnel qui permet
d'être beaucoup mieux fournis sur tous
les produits que ce soit de première
nécessité ou tout ce que vous avez
besoin que le marché traditionnel qui
est récurrente pénurie et finalement il
faudra arriver à un enjeu crucial aura
une question comme celle qu'on n'a pas
traité encore jusqu'à maintenant tu es
la question de l'embargo et de des états
unis qui est en place depuis soixante
dix ans et puis bien trop longtemps et
qui est justement la cause principale du
fait que cuba a du mal à se fournir a du
mal à apporter puisque si jamais il
n'avait pas cet embargo ils auront
beaucoup plus de facilité avec au maire
alain commercer avec beaucoup plus
d'entreprises pour pouvoir rapporter
alors qu'aujourd'hui ils sont obligés de
passer par des mécanismes à la marge
plutôt de l'économie et des échanges
traditionnels et qui effectivement ne ne
permettent pas de manière sereine de
pouvoir importer les produits dont les
cubains ont besoin julienne quelques
hoquets remercie en tout cas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions vous êtes haut
responsable international des jeunes
d'insoumis et spécialiste de l'amérique
du sud merci à vous merci